megan's in owensboro kentucky hi megan
welcome
to the ramsay show hi dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
okay so my husband and i um we just sold
our current home
and we have met with some builders um
and we are we have plans to build a home
but i've recently started channeling in
with you and listening to all of your
advice and all about the baby steps we
have well over 20
down but we still have some vehicle debt
how much do you own your vehicles why
would you
45 000 holy crap
what are you driving um
well that's kind of another story but my
husband um had a rough year last year
and he actually bought two different
vehicles without telling me
um a toyota so this is the way he this
is the way he medicates he goes and buys
cars
yeah it seems that way ouch
spit just spends money in general um
cars
and and clothes and just
different different things yeah
okay uh so if we
get on a good track and get rid of the
vehicle debt unless we fix that
you're gonna be right back into a mess
aren't you
yeah so i think we start with him
does he does he want to work does he
want to work a system to build wealth or
does he want to continue to be a
freaking child
he he's all he says he's on board with
this
um plan that i want to you know
basically your plan
good sell the trucks and i know you say
not to modify
no just sell the trucks sell the cars
yeah let's see if he's on plan he's not
on plan
i don't believe you no and you don't
believe you
no not really i'm sorry baby girl
yeah you guys got to work through that
stuff because that's that's
the these trucks and financial problems
are the symptom
they're not the problem so
right ken if they dig in and get on the
same page really
then it what's your household income by
the way
um about 115. okay
and which which two vehicles do we buy
what are they
um it's a brand new toyota tacoma and a
vintage
like 1960s mustang okay
how old is your husband we uh we're both
31.
okay um and we have about
80 000 right now um saved
without you know for the for the
potential
you guys can decide what you want to do
you're both um
walking around in 30 year old bodies and
so it's legal for you to do whatever you
want to do
as far as these issues go what would i
tell you to do
if you were my kid and my kid is your
age okay
my my grown kids watch her show too yeah
the ramsey rachel's 33
okay so what would i tell you all to do
if
winston and rachel sat down in front of
me with this um
i'm going to tell you what i have done
to myself
in these situations i would sell the
vehicles
not because it's necessary but because
you need to prove to yourself and he
needs to prove to himself
that we're going to start being
grown-ups and both of these cars were
impulse medicaid
medicated purchases that is what you
described he's medicating having a bad
year in air quotes
um and um
uh uh you know you need to break i
went and if i can do something and pull
it off
and it makes my dumb decision earlier
go away then it makes me more likely to
go back to the dumb decision versus if i
amputate these vehicles i have to
feel it then and let me tell you i'm a
car guy
and getting rid of a vintage 60s mustang
makes my stomach hurt right now just
telling you to do that because i
wouldn't be able to do it
i mean i could do it but that just makes
my that's i'm hurting i'm hurting yeah
ken's got a great carmen gia he's
redoing right now i love classic cars
yeah look i i just want to say this meg
you got to break the cycle of this and
the spirit of this is more important
than the actual math
yeah and after the discipline he's gonna
have to get a vision you two are gonna
have to come together this is a marriage
thing
and you guys at 31 have got to get a
vision what do we want for our lives
that isn't just stuff he's going after
stuff we've all done stuff before
to to make things feel better but what's
the big vision
and it'll help him with this as dave
says kari amputation if he's got
a big vision that you two hopefully on
the same page for what do we want for
our lives
what does it look like 20 years from now
this is a big decision
and and to the best of your ability i'd
get with a counselor is what i think i
think this is a
we need to get on the same page about
this money thing
because it's coming out of another place
that's going to get us in big trouble
so either you put 40 000 down on your
house and you keep these cars
paid pay them off or you sell them and
you put 80 000
on the house and you have
proven that you're moving in a different
direction emotionally
and spiritually away from this stuff
addiction
that's what i would want to do if i were
looking in his mirror and i was
him that's called manhood baby